i
[Música]
en el tercer día de protestas en ecuador
los indígenas comienzan a llegar a quito
el ministerio del interior dice que
tiene cómo responder ante la situación y
ya van 20 detenidos en esta división
conectaremos con nuestro corresponsal en
chip
la reserva federal estadounidense subió
las tasas de interés en 75 puntos
básicos es el incremento más alto que ha
tomado de una sola vez desde 1994 podría
haber una recesión el organismo ha
actuado tarde contra la inflación lo
analizaremos en minutos
mil millones de dólares más destinará a
eeuu para armar a ucrania este nuevo
monto es adicional a los 40 mil millones
que aprobó el congreso de mayo y le dará
al país europeo municiones como cohetes
y artillería
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
yo soy maría clara calle y es un placer
estar con ustedes comenzamos en ecuador
con las protestas que ya completan tres
días consecutivos ya empiezan a llegar
los indígenas a quitó a lo que el
ministro del interior patricio carrillo
respondió que las autoridades tienen
controlada la situación por otro lado
nueve provincias son las que tienen más
vías interrumpidas incluida pichincha
donde está la capital los indígenas
lideran la protesta ante el alza del
costo de vida y especialmente del precio
del combustible conectamos a esta hora
con nuestro corresponsal en quito-
gustavo ortega gustavo buenas noches y
bienvenidos cuéntenos qué está pasando
con la movilización y cómo está
respondiendo el gobierno ecuatoriano
sí buenas noches más la cala
efectivamente en el tercer día de
movilizaciones indígenas el día de hoy
el ejecutivo nacional tanto la
confederación de nacionalidades
indígenas se ha pronunciado en torno a
lo que ha sido el balance de las
movilizaciones en principio el ejecutivo
nacional ya ha expresado preocupación
por el creciente el tipo de violencia
que poco a poco se ha venido
incrementando el día de hoy se han
venido bloqueando los accesos de ingreso
por la parte sur de la ciudad y de igual
forma también los comuneros y empiezan a
llegar a la ciudad capital ingresaron en
camiones ingresaron caminando
recorrieron la ciudad capital y salieron
de la ciudad capital también empieza a
verse ciertas concentraciones que van
incrementándose en el característico
parque del arbolito una zona de
concentraciones muy características de
protestas en esta ciudad de igual forma
también el ejecutivo nacional ha
minimizado también lo que ha sido la
fuerza de la protesta ha dicho que están
solos
y contabilizan 5000 personas que
estarían protestando en el país no así
los movimientos indígenas han emitido un
pronunciamiento y básicamente leonidas
iza ha llamado a ratificar la protesta y
usted es precisamente menciona a
leonidas iza el presidente de la
confederación de nacionalidades
indígenas y quien fue arrestado el
martes ahora está en libertad
condicional pero su arresto tuvo muchas
irregularidades e hizo que los indígenas
llamaran a protestas más fuertes
cuéntenos qué está pasando en ese caso
si tales como tras la captura de la
unidad y se ha estado muy cuestionada
desde el inicio de su aprensión en la
madrugada del día martes tanto el
ejecutivo nacional como la confederación
de nacionalidades indígenas ha
cuestionado la forma como fue apresado
en principio unidosis a aseguraba que él
no estaba cometiendo ningún tipo de
delito de flagrancia tal y como se lee
intenta procesar ha dicho la jueza del
caso que se espera que será procesado en
libertad pero por el delito de bloqueo
de vías públicas para sin embargo el
ejecutivo en nacional si asegura que
estaba cometiendo un delito en este
sentido también leonidas iza asegura que
no se le leyeron los derechos va sin
embargo el ejecutivo nacional si lo
justifica y ha dicho que posteriormente
mostró un vídeo donde se le leía sus
derechos en un lugar diferente donde fue
capturado lo cierto es que el día de hoy
es ratifica mantener la protesta hasta
conseguir una respuesta por parte del
ejecutivo nacional gustavo gracias por
toda esta información y cambiamos de
noticia porque los candidatos
presidenciales
vuelta electoral en colombia tendrán que
asistir a un debate así lo ordenó el
tribunal superior de bogotá que además
precisó que esta discusión pública debe
darse a más tardar el jueves 16 de junio
y es que el populista rodolfo hernández
se había negado a debatir con su
contendor izquierdista gustavo petro
ahora por orden de un juez deberá
defender sus propuestas abiertamente
esto antes del balotaje del próximo
domingo 19 de junio
a propósito de los comicios colombianos
rodolfo hernández no es un candina un
candidato convencional es un empresario
nacido en santander en el noreste del
país que formó su fortuna en la
industria inmobiliaria su campaña ha
estado marcada por las redes sociales
una de las razones por las que obtuvo
más de 6 millones de votos en la primera
vuelta y está a un paso de ser
presidente manuel a cano y benyamine bar
nos cuentan las que teníamos hecho de
las en sus redes sociales lo llaman el
viejito con cariño
pero tras bambalinas son estos 13
jóvenes los que han catapultado la
campaña política de rodolfo hernández a
diario rompen paradigmas las ideas se
construyen entre dos no salen sólo de mí
ni salen sólo de ellos incluso son del
ingeniero a veces el a veces hay cosas
que dice porque no se hace un texto con
tal cosa veces como kaká la tele
aterrizamos las ideas y lo construimos
entre todos como no son especialistas en
marketing político manejan la campaña
como si se encargarán de vender un
producto la imagen del ingeniero lo dota
de valor digamos que todas las
estrategias y tácticas que nosotros
hacemos utilizan en redes sociales con
otro personaje con otro con otro
candidato tendrían que ser otra vez
realmente él es el protagonista de todo
es muy muy muy comunicador
y su candidatura ya es una marca los
bumangueses son sus mayores consumidores
en la capital de santander al noreste de
colombia
muchos son fanáticos lo siguen desde que
fue alcalde a pesar de un mandato
marcado por tres suspensiones
el ingeniero formó su fortuna y su
reputación en el sector inmobiliario
para jairo grimaldos arquitecto de su
constructora hg el político y el
empresario son dos caras de la misma
moneda es sobradamente medieval ésta es
lo más sencillo así como son campañas
simple inicia enseña a pocos kilómetros
de bucaramanga en la plaza central de
piedecuesta su ciudad natal se exhibe
ese minimalismo
esta casa modelo es una de sus promesas
miles serían entregadas a campesinos en
toda colombia
el proyecto ilusiona
pero propuestas como ésta le han valido
el adjetivo de populista mientras que el
ex concejal jon claro lo califica de
mentiroso
en su estudio sobresale en las pruebas
de su versión sobre el día en que
hernández lo agredió físicamente
pero más allá de la mediática cachetada
claro cuestiona su famoso discurso
anticorrupción sea el único candidato
que está siendo acusado por corrupción y
que va en un proceso de juicio oral que
muy pronto él lo atenderé entonces se
contrapone si estoy luchando contra la
evolución porque estoy siendo
investigado y acusado tick tock el
empresario e ingeniero los componentes
de una fórmula que rompe con la política
tradicional y por la que rodolfo
hernández apuesta para llegar a la
presidencia vamos a eeuu la reserva
federal anunció que incrementará su tasa
de interés en 75 puntos básicos es la
subida más alta que ha habido desde 1994
la fed explicó que la medida es para
bajar la histórica inflación que
enfrenta el país
el aumento de 75 puntos básicos de hoy
es inusualmente grande y no espero que
los movimientos de este tipo sean
comunes desde la perspectiva actual en
nuestra próxima reunión parece más
probable un aumento de 50 puntos básicos
o de 75 puntos básicos sin embargo
tomaremos nuestras decisiones reunión
por y continuaremos comunicando nuestro
pensamiento tan claramente como podamos
para analizar el tema nos acompaña desde
nuevo méxico jorge romero javier
economista y profesor de western new
méxico y unidad city he venido a
france24 en la vida cotidiana
explíquenos cómo se sentirá este aumento
de la tasa de interés de la reserva
federal
bueno estamos viendo a subidas en
intereses que todos los consumidores
usamos no por ejemplo a la deuda que la
gente sacan para comprar casas se ha
notado que ha afectado ese mercado
porque se ha bajado la cantidad de deuda
que se está sacando pero ese interés
afecta a muchas de las cosas que el
consumidor normal
tiene acceso para pagar su día a día
para vivir y uno de los grandes miedos
es que esta política monetaria agresiva
pueda generar una recesión económica en
eeuu usted cree que esto podría suceder
sí claro es extremadamente una realidad
y hay mucha gente que ya hay muchos
economistas y políticos que ya están
hablando de ese tema
la realidad es que estamos en una
economía no sólo aquí en eeuu el
premundial que es una economía de
burbuja que se ha inflado por la
política del centro del banco central de
eeuu y el banco central de muchos países
a estos niveles de intereses son
históricamente artificial bajó y el
nivel que lo ha subido el feder ahora
históricamente no es mucho y si miramos
la última vez que la inflación estaba
así de alta
estamos hablando hace 40 años y era un
nivel que
en los niveles de interés es que el fed
tuvo que llegar para poder calmar esa
inflación fueron 12 por ciento ahora
mismo estamos hablando de un interés de
1% y medio que no es nada comparada
mente así que en una economía basada en
deuda un interés alto obviamente va a
tener una influencia muy muy negativa y
precisamente usted habla de que la
subida no ha sido tan alta como en otras
ocasiones y a propósito la fed ha sido
criticada porque en un inicio defendió
que la inflación sería pasajera y ahora
quedó claro que no cree que la fed actuó
tarde ante la inflación
sí claro actúe extremamente tarde y no
está actuando muy agresivamente tampoco
históricamente hay una economista que
aquí dice que el hierro aunque está en
cargo del pérez está hablando como paul
volcker que era que estaba en cargo del
fer en los 80s pero en realidad está
actuando como ben bernanke que estaba en
cargo de como el 2008 2007 y como alan
greenspan que fue el que infló la
burbuja de la economía aquí en el
principio en el 2000 en los dosmiles y
después bernanke y lo siguió etcétera
así que así tarde y no suficiente
siquiera un punto donde el interés
gracias gracias por estar con nosotros
eeuu destinará mil millones de dólares
para dar más en ucrania un presupuesto
adicional al que ya aprobó el congreso
por 40 mil millones de dólares en mayo
la nueva ayuda está dividida en dos
categorías artículos de defensa que
pertenecen hasta ahora a las fuerzas
estadounidenses y otro para financiar
nuevo armamento todo esto incluye
sistemas de cohetes antiguo que cohetes
de artillería obuses y municiones el
presidente ucraniano volodymyr selenski
agradeció el respaldo
si no está de eeuu anunció un nuevo
fortalecimiento de nuestra defensa un
nuevo paquete de apoyo de mil millones
de dólares pero we
se trata de defensa costera artillería y
modernos sistemas de cohetes
estaremos esperando ya es estoy
agradecido por este apoyo es
especialmente importante para nuestra
defensa en la región del donbass
shandong vice la comisión europea lanzó
este miércoles una nueva acción judicial
en contra del reino unido bruselas ha
acusado a londres de poner en peligro la
paz en irlanda del norte por tratar de
revisar un acuerdo comercial pues
preside la medida empeora las relaciones
entre la unión europea y londres desde
que los británicos salieron del bloque
de los 27 veamos
la posición de la comisión europea es
firme no se puede revisar el acuerdo
comercial post pre éxito sobre la
frontera con la irlanda del norte
londres había lanzado este lunes una
revisión unilateral bruselas contestó
con procesos judiciales contra el país
colts speights spect crisis y liga es
ilegal el proyecto de la ley británica
es extremadamente perjudicial para la
confianza mutua se ha creado una
profunda incertidumbre y ha enturbiado
nuestra cooperación mundial en un
momento en el que el cumplimiento de los
acuerdos internacionales nunca ha sido
tan importantes a servín moore
importante cuando reino unido dejó la
unión europea ambas partes acordaron
mantener la frontera terrestre entre la
república de irlanda e irlanda del norte
si impuestos de aduanas una condición
esencial en el proceso de paz que puso
fin a décadas de violencia en la región
para proteger el mercado único de la
unión europea londres y bruselas habían
acordado realizar controles de
determinadas mercancías el proyecto de
ley de boris johnson propone ahora de
eliminar algunos de esos controles
afirmando que pusieron a irlanda en
desventaja
debido a la burocracia aduanera hemos
visto menos mercancías entrar en irlanda
del norte las hemos visto más caras y
también hemos visto como las empresas
británicas no comercian
bruselas anunció la apertura de dos
nuevos procedimientos por incumplimiento
de los controles de mercancías y el
relanzamiento de un tercero suspendido
en septiembre de 2021 por violación del
protocolo esto puede dar lugar a un
recurso ante el tribunal de justicia de
las comunidades europeas y a sanciones
y terminamos en washington pues la calle
enfrente de la embajada de arabia
saudita cambió de nombre y ahora se
llamará llama al hashtag y esto en honor
al periodista asesinado en el consulado
saudí está en estambul hace cuatro años
el hombro de los activistas para
renombrar la calle y así hacer una
presión simbólica llega semanas antes de
que el presidente estadounidense joe
biden viaje a arabia saudita el
mandatario se reunirá con el príncipe
heredero mohamed bin salman
hasta aquí las noticias sigan con
nosotros
[Música]